[Music]
Staples like wheat Maize and rice Feed
the World providing nearly half the
calories we eat
but in many regions these crops and our
access to them are under threat
there's definitely an urgency to find
alternatives to the current Food Systems
especially in the current context that
we're in now where you've had Supply
chains disrupted by covid where you have
the Ukraine Russia War which has reduced
the amount of wheat available where you
have climate change making it more
difficult to access water sources
current Global conditions have created
the worst Food security crisis in West
Africa for a decade
and nearly 40 million people in the
Sahel region are semi-arid belt across
North Africa and now facing hunger
but fonio a small grain native to that
region has the potential to help many
ways for you is the crop of the future
but it's unable to lift it up potential
because of how much it's been neglected
in the past
it tastes like couscous but what it has
over couscous is that it's gluten free
it's easy to digest it's protein Rich
anti-glycemic which means that it helps
fight diabetes and it's also very
filling
but most importantly fonio is drought
resistant and can grow in poor soil
it only grows in the Sahel region and a
belt of Savannah below it
it's cultivated mainly for sustenance in
lean Times by local communities like the
nomadic Fulani
Fulani is really one of the predominant
ethnic groups in the Sahel
Chef fatmata binta is from Syria Leon
and based in Ghana
and so she's of that ethnicity she was a
refugee and eighth fonio to survive with
her family
I want to decolonize African cuisine
because the questions I was asking
myself when I was in culinary school was
why am I cooking the food I didn't grow
up eating
it makes sense to me also why food
should travel miles
to come to my kitchen before I serve it
to someone
after going to culinary school in Kenya
and working at top hotels in Accra chef
at Mata binta toured the world with a
pop-up restaurant that gave others a
chance to taste her culture with a focus
on fonio
it's an ancient green it has been around
for a very long time we believe over 7
000 years
very easy to grow so if you think about
a sustainable green that's the first
green that will come to mind for me you
don't need to plow the land too much to
grow it
and it's a tiny grain like the size of
sand
the size of the phonio grains is a
problem
being so small and wrapped in a Husk
that has to be removed before it's eaten
makes it extremely hard and tedious to
process
and in most places the processing hasn't
changed for millennia
foreign
[Music]
from the stem
the woman will stomp on Roots while they
are singing and dancing that's their way
of also you know having that Community
Sisterhood bonding
[Music]
do trying to get the sand out of the
phone you know after stomping
and then they'll pound it still toast it
it takes like a week or two to process
technological innovation is a must if
phonos ever to be a serious Contender as
a crop of the future there are only 700
000 tons of It produced annually
compared to over 700 million tons of
wheat
about 75 of all phonio comes from Guinea
at a point the former president of
Guinea president Alpha Conde who was
actually deposing a coup became a big
advocate for fonio
he used to travel to neighboring
countries on diplomatic missions and
carrying a bag of fonio to give to his
counterparts because he recognized that
there was an export market and that he
could earn foreign currency by exporting
fonio and so there was a push to
mechanize fonio
[Music]
about a dozen countries can grow for new
but in Guinea they actually have quite a
few Mills which is not the case for the
other countries
those machine are very helpful because
it's helped us to increase our
productivity before the machine for the
production of one ton we can take three
weeks now that we have the machine we
can just make three days or four days
the even Mills in Guinea's Capital
Concrete haven't mechanized the entire
process
and so de-husking often still happens
the traditional way
funniest kind of got a reputation in
Western media as the superfoods that had
this quinoa potential but it hasn't
really taken off
there is not enough phonia being grown
at least at a commercial level and
there's not enough processing facility
is actually considered a neglected and
underutilized crop species that's
actually a scientific category which is
also called an orphan crop which means
it's been a under researched crop
more research could help improve yields
and bring the production process into
the 21st century
but to gain more traction ambassadors
like Chef binta are crucial to spreading
the word about phonio's potential
there's something so powerful about food
and and I believe it's it can break down
barriers it's a bridge
I get to collaborate a lot with Michelin
star chefs I will send them for new and
then challenge them to create something
because I believe that's how you spark
conversation and that's how you educate
people and expose it to the world
[Music]
local exposure is also crucial
even though fonio grows in Northern
Ghana in the Region's biggest city there
tamale the grain is nowhere to be found
it's been so much and green that's been
kept for Farmer households but even
though I describe it as a farmer crop
it's actually very expensive to buy
fonio it's about eight times more
expensive than rice than the same
quantity of rice and that's why if you
want to buy it as an outsider it's
actually very expensive it's a
ceremonial meal
foreign
what would also happen is that the cost
of phonia would go down
but there needs to be a value chain for
phone yo for there to be more players uh
more manufacturers more people who grow
it if you don't change mindsets quickly
and bring Investments people actually
going to forget the skill because it's
only traditional and there needs to be a
point where people both researchers
industry governments decide that they
need to invest in this as a real
solution
[Applause]
Chef binta is one of many who were
taking phono seriously so seriously in
fact she's willing to bet her own
livelihood on it she's now moving to
tamale to work directly with farmers and
try to build the value chain from the
ground up
[Applause]
now spend days with the locals the
keepers of the authentic recipes these
women take time to teach me they're
passing down knowledge they're passing
down sustainable traditions and it
didn't feel right to walk away go back
to my kitchen and not um
recognize what they are going to so I
wanted to collaborate with them in a
more meaningful way
so the main goal is to partner with
women who are going for new already in
and out of Ghana and who have a center
where I will process we package and then
we distribute locally and
internationally and I believe look we
have to start locally because we have to
place value first locally and then we
can scale it foreign
[Music]